now let me ask you man who do you live
with at your house
don't know which question you answered
[Applause]
because i don't think it was the one
that i asked i
am i wrong did he answer the question i
i don't like it
i'm gonna go back to you one more time
because you told me
well you were like yeah i pooped the
door open i said okay i'm gonna come
back to you
and then i said
oh my god i don't know what the [ __ ] is
happening right now
okay okay so who who are you with
all right do you have an accent or you
just developed one so nobody thinks
you're with him
i'm not with this guy i can't place the
accent what
what's the accent what is it
okay what are the odds that i'm talking
to you and i'm looking at him uh
where where are you from man
not really uh okay you know what i'm
pretty much done with this table
so everyone say good night to them
uh
yeah it was just did you stroke out dude
you all right
yeah that was a weird noise
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
always interesting at these shows isn't
it
yeah man i mean we're still waiting for
a little finger banging from this day
beggars can't beep shoes just stop um
watch he's going to have tourette's or
some [ __ ] and come after me after the
show
that that was [ __ ] up god to say to me
thanks dude because i didn't give a [ __ ]
anyways but
[Applause]
that was uh let me you know what you
guys made me do
take my edibles
[Applause]
let's see and by the way guys if you've
ever seen a saturday night show of mine
this is how it goes
it's very loose i try new jokes i talk
to people
who don't make sense um
[Music]
[Music]
you